you gotta die
don't go to russia you [ __ ] idiot i
would like to go to russia is this a
good idea since i am so in love with
bullets i want to go out there i'm not
quite sure if my debit card will work
two months ago i matched with a girl and
we have
so much in common more than any other
girl that i've dated and i've been
around the block so that tells me a lot
we've been talking on the phone and
texting daily i speak russian fluently
so that's no issue i have an
intelligence from alabama i'm a [ __ ]
and i gained feelings for her and so did
she uh she actually asked me if i could
come and visit her and seeing as there's
a ton of strict sanctions in russia um i
could go there but that would not be any
good for me since my credit card and
debit card simply will not work so
clearly that's off the menu so by the
looks of it i have two options i stop
talking to her or i wait until the war
ends and the banking systems go back
into play but
honestly who knows how long that'll be
so what do you recommend i do should we
try and make this work or should i stop
wasting her time i can tell she wants to
keep it going because the second she
wakes up to go to work she texts me the
second she gets home from work she calls
me
she sends me photos of her family or her
nieces
her nephews uh her her mom her sisters i
mean we're really close and uh so i can
tell she wants to keep it going but i'm
not exactly sure she understands that i
probably won't see her for quite a long
time which goes back to me asking myself
should i just end this now and stop
wasting her time
or or not all right here's my don't
here's my impression of this guy right
now
you're getting taken for a ride
wait why
well he's not giving her money
yeah but dude that's what it's leading
to dude she's giving her [ __ ]
pictures of his her niece and [ __ ] like
that's way too much info it's way too
much info it's not real dude this is
this dude right here
you gotta take it for a while
i
actually didn't even think that i don't
think i agree she's not asking him for
money dude not yet dude because right
now it's just like this i'm gonna add a
caveat to everything i'm saying i i i
if she ever asks you for money
then everything i'm saying
flushes down the [ __ ] toilet but
what i would say is came what i would
say is
you [ __ ]
what i don't like what i don't like is
when [ __ ] like take it upon
themselves to decide for some woman to
be like oh you don't know what you're
getting into like she's not a [ __ ]
adult she's an adult she can decide
whatever the [ __ ] she wants if you don't
want to keep doing it then you don't do
it but don't take her agency away from
me like
you don't know what you're getting into
sweetheart trust me this is a way bigger
deal than you realize i'm gonna cut i'm
gonna cut the cord now because you don't
know what you're getting into don't do
that it's not your responsibility it's
your responsibility to look out for you
and don't be a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] too
hard now if she asks you for money
you're gonna take it for a ride and
you're a [ __ ] idiot
and i can tell you want to say something
because you won't stop moving so go
ahead
that's my is that my
dude that's him i think you missed my
but nothing's happened yet
that's why he's
he's not like let me out
yeah but a lot of guys willfully give
women money that they've never met
before right and that's fine but dude my
point is you gotta dude you have to just
you're get you're why can't she can she
come see him i was going to say get her
the [ __ ] out of russia get her out of
hey dude go away
from the war part yeah
and also go away get the people you love
away from the war yeah why are you
wanting to go over there you guys talk
about debit and credit cards you're
gonna die dude don't go to russia you
[ __ ] my question is here is the deal
i can speak russian fluently i love when
bullets are whizzing by my head
sometimes i love when bullets hit my
head um i would like to go to russia is
this a good idea since i am so in love
with bullets riddling my body and
whizzing by my head and sometimes
hitting my head they're not fighting you
guys
in russia i know i know i know i get it
but also it's a bad idea to go to russia
while russia is waging a [ __ ] war
yeah dude on ukraine and potentially uh
more of the world obviously don't do
that
full stop if she's so [ __ ] into you
as well
get her the [ __ ] out of there and have
her join you wherever you are in [ __ ]
alabama or wherever you are just take
the seat belt off buddy and get out
this is a ride one way or another it is
dude also there's people around you
hey guy
look yeah just go outside you should
look closer than right now i mean dude
it couldn't be further
i am on a dating app that is actually
intergalactical um i met this person who
was four foot six and she's on pluto and
it's uh it is weird kind of face timing
her because her helmet gets in the way
i have not seen her full face uh she is
green her nose is astronomically big and
she has three penises but those are the
females on pluto
i want to go out there i'm not quite
sure if my debit card will work
mean dude do you hear yourself
do me a favor play this back
[Music]